normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let's
jump to this story we have a tweet from
Patrick Bet David it's a Redemption Arc
for Chris Cuomo Patrick Bet David tweets
Chris Cuomo trending for being open to
the idea of voting for Trump people are
losing their minds over this and he is
certainly correct let's play the clip
it's a it's about 2 minutes long we'll
just we'll play a little bit of it it's
if it's Biden Trump look for me again um
we survive a trump
Administration uh would we survive
another one yes yes I don't think
there's any greater risk To America with
him than with Biden and for people who
are now going to attack me and say what
are you talking about Trump is like this
crazy man well look you know as Patrick
says the data is the data nobody was
trying to kill us when Trump was
president in a way that they're not now
if anything there's more hostility and
you can have reasons for that any way
you want I'm just is saying
existentially I'm not afraid of a trump
presidency um existentially I'm not
afraid of another Biden presidency
because unlike many people in America I
believe that the country is much
stronger than any individual leader um
we survived the Russia thing we survived
January 6th we survived having Biden as
a gaff machine we survived uh Congress
uh going after each other and doing
nothing for the rest of us we survive
these things are we better for it no uh
should we be doing things differently
yes I think it happens I don't know when
I don't even know why but you know in
terms of who I'm going to vote for I
would really have to see where we are at
that moment in
time uh and so you're open to Trump vote
I am always open and I'll tell you this
people say you've never voted
for a republican in your life wrong and
not only we get it we get it he's trying
his Redemption Arc at first I was afraid
he just breaks into the music that's the
official death of the cuomosexual tattoo
right there anybody who has one they're
getting they watch us go all right I was
on the fence but I'm getting that thing
lasered off all those all those shirts I
kind of want to buy one now you know
like LeBron when he like went to the
Heat and everybody's burning their
cuomosexual shirts
cuomosexual that's for homosexual right
now like you you suffered through Andrew
now Chris is forsaking you yeah was what
is it Chris Andrew wants to be Governor
again or something yeah I think he maybe
wants to be mayor of New York City you
guys you guys are still in New York
right yeah is is it because you have
something wrong with you they all no New
York no those guys all kind of like they
get they don't they lose one election
and by the end of it they're just like
campaigning to be like a condo board
president just there's like I need some
need some position the library board
what do you guys think New York New
York's one of the sickest cities in the
world you're right it is sick it's awful
you think Chris Cuomo is just trying to
he's trying to find his Redemption Arc
he's already been doing that well he was
making $10 million a year at CNN I'm
sure he's trying to like some sort of
paycheck he's and he's also like
podcasting now he realizes this you know
his just like whatever the mainstream
thinks I think is not going to work
anymore so he's trying to show that he
has Nu on no no no no no it's it's quite
the opposite he's the whatever the
mainstream thinks I will say when he was
was no no no and now that he's going
into the podcast space when he's
actually dealing with real people it's
the independent voter base is 2 to one
Trump over over Biden so all he's doing
is adapting to the environment he's in
now yeah he's doing the exact same
that's what I just said no one ever
challeng CNN but but my my I'm saying if
he was still at CNN he wouldn't be
saying this that's point I agree I agree
my point was simply the podcast world is
the mainstream and he's simply doing the
same thing he's he's just towing a line
for whatever the popular narrative
is maybe less so just mainstream not
mainstream it's like you if you're going
to be doing these three-hour interviews
with all different sorts of people you
have to sort of show that you have some
nuance and he wants people to see him as
a reasonable guy and listen to his
podcast that's that's how I see it
people have asked me if I would have him
on and I'm like yeah I'd love to the
first question is why did you fake being
in quarantine yeah that's when you watch
that video him coming up out of his
basement be like oh I never left the
house and then people are like but we
saw him outside but and his son is
watching him lie and just his son's face
is just so so much respect lying kids
right now this gu this guy this guy will
never come on this show that you can
listen listen Cuomo will never come on
this show will because the first
question is why did you fake being in
now you said he got tons of time and I'm
absolutely going to say and the second
question is do you think your children
are worse off for having watched you lie
on television that way no I think
they're better well that's a good
question but I think that his kid might
be a big part of the reason why he's not
doing it I get I get people saying oh
Tim when you insult these people now
they won't come on your show I'm like oh
like okay too bad what this dude did was
contributing to psychotic
authoritarian author just government
fascistic Nazi garbage I think people
are breaking out of the Empire like
they're shattering their allegiance to
the Empire and by that I mean like the
dark Empire of Star Wars and they're
coming too and they're they're
definitely willing to be like yo maybe
this Rebellion ain't I just think he go
back I think CNN in a second he's from a
political like huge political family
like he in his mind's yeah you lie
because it's for the greater good and
he's in New York that's like where all
of his connections are they're all
probably still attached to CNN like it's
not only his like Life religion and
Social Circle it's how he values himself
so he might do this right now but if CNN
was like we'll cut you like a quarter of
the check we gave you he'd be like okay
sounds good I think he would go back and
be the weatherman if they that check
Lally if if if he really did want to
come on the show knowing I will ask him
all these questions that would I would I
would respect that 100% yeah I mean I
think if he's going I haven't seen the
whole Patrick B Davis but if he went on
there for 3 hours I can't imagine he was
getting Patrick be David does not do the
kid gloves treatment so agreed agreed
yeah and that's kind of wild to me
because I feel like Patrick B David
actually goes harder than I do he does
like when he brought out the boots for
Ronda santis like wow dude like Patrick
B David is awesome that was amazing I
would never do that like I don't know if
I have the balls to pull out a pair of
boots and be like put them on Ron you
know I mean take take your can't gifts I
can't gifts I'm willing to ask the
question but I don't I don't know about
actually like put him on pck is L like
all right we're going back to back shoes
off right
now competition let's settle this yeah
he's big awesome he's real big and
muscular he's got that Vibe like I'm a
soldier he was yeah dude yeah great
great show by the way and man yeah
you've been on his show several times
it's amazing he's he's a good dude and I
really respect and appreciate how he he
brings his people on bringing on weener
bringing on Cuomo that was a great
episode weer did you guys see break no
freebies no freebies calls him out so I
respect it I tend to think like I'm My
Own Worst Enemy and that if I do talk
crap about people before I even give
them a chance that I'm ruining my own
pathway my own career so I I air on the
side of he maybe Chris is down to jam
man let's let's talk about the weird
stuff let's talk about what life was
like at CNN and make a better career
he'd be an interesting guest to talk
about like what was life at CNN because
obviously we have a lot of strong
opinions about it and the mainstream
media generally but I I think it would
be you know it would be unlikely that he
would come on again because I think
someone much of it is tied to I
eventually want to end up back in the
hive yeah it is possible though it's the
other way where he actually hated what
his job was for the last four years
where it was like here's what you got to
do
got it is possible that like behind
closed doors he was going home and he's
like I got to say this freaking garbage
at work like he might have not liked
that that would have been cool and if he
could come on and tell us that I would
like it a lot yeah I accept that like we
we we talk about Bud Light and how we
want to be mad at budlight for
sponsoring Dylan milany but now that
they're sponsoring UFC you know credit
to Shan Strickland who pointed out
they're now backing the opinions of all
these MMA fighters who are based now
it's kind of like okay I I think we got
to give Bud Light a little bit because
we don't get the apology we want but
them backing UFC they're going to be
putting money behind the words of all
these MMA fighters that's like a big
victory yeah I was sort of saying this
uh even before we started but I'm a
fairly forgiving person uh for that kind
of stuff like I I don't hold the opinion
that if someone uh screwed up or said
something I don't like or whatever you
know that forever you're just like that
guy's off limits you got to give him a
path to Redemption so if we say to Bud
Light no matter what you do we will
never buy your product then they're
going to say okay well at least we can
capture a small Market if we go back the
other direction towards the left if we
say you know what bud like you sponsored
UFC so we're actually going to start
buying again then they're going to be
like sponsor more of this stuff and that
means they're going to put more money
into people we do like and opinions we
do like I guess you're talking about the
actual basis of uh you know voting with
your dollars exactly so we want these
companies to sponsor things we like and
stop doing things we don't like so when
Disney makes a whole bunch of weird woke
movies and they fail we don't got to do
anything we just don't have to watch
their crap because we don't like it they
they get the message and they put out to
their investors like Hey we're doing
something wrong so with Bud Light could
you does that mean that you would only
buy Bud Light at like a UFC event
because if I assume they separate their
grocery sales right I will buy Bud Light
the next time we get a UFC fighter with
the budlight symbol and he says
something and then Bud Light just
accepts it because what I'm worried
about is Sean stri will come out at a
press conference for like a championship
fight or or whenever he's fighting next
and he's going to say here are my
thoughts on politics xyzabc and then
budlight goes we do not support these
opinions and we reject this then I'm
going to be like okay that's the test if
the guy says it and people go budlight
why you sponsoring this and budlight
ignores it I'll buy budlight yeah I
think they will I think they probably
decided that they know this is going to
happen and probably that's the
rehabilitation is by saying like yep we
we sponsor the UFC that's we we don't
sponsor the individuals we're just here
for UFC the fight can say what they want
I'll be like I'll take it I mean you
hope they would have learned their
lesson yeah you might call it an AB test
get it anheiser Bush it's such a lame
joke you you made a good point a while
ago Ian you said that you lost the
confidence Ian I made a point a while
ago that that uh sometimes you'll work
with evil people to do good and and he's
completely correct the motivations of
the anheiser bush people may be
absolutely nefarious in fact let's let's
bring it back to Cuomo Cuomo may be a
lying manipulative piece of garbage
who is going on pbd and trying to lie to
people to win favor and you know what
doesn't mean I trust him but when he's
saying he's open to voting for Trump and
now there's a lot of people who are
going to be like you know what I'm
willing to listen now you think he saw
Rapaport getting all the press for it
and he's like I I getting some news
stories here he may be an evil guy but
if what he's doing contributes to good
I'm not going to condemn him for doing
something that's beneficial people have
a lot of people have been roped up in
this system this corporate fascist
system and it's understandable there's a
lot of money you get famous you can s
give your kids good healthy food they
can grow up smart but you know it is
nice to see people cracking out of it
yeah I don't know if I trust him but I
think he said something good so okay all
right take it you know even if it's just
open open to it yeah this this what we
see with like him and rap aore awesome I
bet you s no you I just bet you a guy
like him it's like you break down all
this stuff he's not crazy ideologically
I bet this is just a guy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net